well this was an Algeria brokered
agreement Algiers obviously really
trying to make it a little history and
the certainty is history making it is
and the real country that's making
history is Saudi Arabia two years ago
Saudi Arabia instigated a no-pet policy
that said we have to grab market share
we have to defeat shale we should
produce as much as we can that ended
today its OPEC back OPEC managing the
global oil market OPEC bringing barrels
out to raise prices so it's a it's of
surprise and it's a very big change for
the old market to adjust avani so well I
know that we are still figuring out the
details here about what exactly led to
this decision but as you point out the
big question mark was over was hanging
over Saudi Arabia how they were going to
you know come to these talks if you
could speculate in some sense I mean
what sort of were the pressure points
that could have gotten this agreement to
happen I think what's changed a Saudi
view is that you're seeing increasing
pressure on their economy they're facing
a massive budget deficit we saw this
week that they cut bonuses for all their
government employees they've delayed a
massive bond issue I think what we'll
find is that lower oil prices were
really beginning to bite on the Saudi
economy and they had to change tack they
need places to be higher and also they
needed to head off the risk of a fall
back towards $30 this winter like we saw
the previous January so this will really
yep sorry funny Russia is not obviously
participating in fact it's increased by
four hundred thousand a day how much
will this offset the impact it will be
very interesting to see how Russia
reacts to this proposal I think what
we've been hearing from the Russians is
let OPEC do a deal and then we'll come
to the table to talk about how we might
help to balance the market whether we'll
see that I'm not sure as you point out
Russia has been producing at a record
pace so even if they froze production it
wouldn't change the fundamentals much
and I think actually for Russia to cut
production is unlikely but we'll see
very quickly will will this put prices
up at the pump or we just see us shale
producers come into
to fill the gap if you like it's that's
going to be a very interesting question
whether how quickly this drink she'll
back into the market how quickly show
producers hedge putting downward
pressure on prices but if OPEC stick to
this agreement they will bring the
market back into balance far faster than
most analysts are expecting and
ultimately that means high gasoline
prices for all of us